good morning it's Friday it's actually
Thursday but tomorrow I'm going to be in
airports all day now I know what you're
saying Hank but John I can tell from the
great speckled walls behind you that you
are currently in an airport that's true
but today I'm just in two airports
tomorrow I'm gonna be in a ton of them
huh I am the sleepiest sleepyhead in
sleep Sylvania do I have the vague
remnants of a Harry Potter's card drawn
on my forehead no apology so Hank today
is the last day of pizza miss which
means that it is the last day that you
can buy any of these things with my
mustachioed face on them so if you want
to glow-in-the-dark Pizza John sugar and
David Bowie Pizza John shirt or if you
want to dress your baby in a pizza John
onesie today is the last day link in the
doobly-doo
in other news I am very very tired guard
olivine and not wolf and I did our
modeling phases yesterday
Hank we've all been practicing our model
phases Cara's are pretty good one
so funny I can't it's so great all right
that is a pretty good one normal no it's
better when you try it's better when you
dry your sincere model face can't do the
cheap thing no just you know you go what
are you open your mouth a little bit
that one that one is the good one Hank
was there really good
no tube is my normal face and this is my
model face like so subtle yeah I think
everyone involved in the Paper Towns
movie is doing such a great job and I
don't know how they do it because the
hours are incredibly long like all I'm
doing is like sitting in a chair eating
peanut M&Ms laughing and crying as all
of these hard-working people bring this
story to life and yet despite the
ridiculous
easiness of my job I am truly the most
fatigued fatigued person in all of
fatigued Ville so anyway thank you to
everyone in the Paper Towns crew who's
gonna stay up until five o'clock in the
morning tonight because that is oh boy I
don't know how you're gonna do it owner
daughters also want to say thanks for
your feedback on project Ross from 2014
I will talk more about that when I'm not
the most exhausted exhausting and all of
its ostia and I cause I want to say that
I really enjoyed pizza messing with you
it's made me feel like uh I don't know
it's just been
really fun good old days kind of feeling
you know would also be fun ain't going
to sleep unfortunately I'm about to be
on a steel cylinder that will hurdle
hundreds of miles an hour through the
thin and unsurvivable atmosphere thirty
thousand feet above sea level and that's
just the kind of environment I like to
sleep in ok Hank I didn't really believe
in myself but I did get some sleep on
the flight now I am in Los Angeles
earlier today I got to be with shailene
woodley and Ansel Elgort and lots of
other people involved in The Fault in
Our Stars movie as an Amsterdam esque
Fault in Our Stars bench was installed
on the Fox lot the Fox lot has a statue
of Napoleon Dynamite murals of The
Simpsons and Star Wars to join that kind
of company it's just uh it's pretty
wonderful and now I am going to go to
bed is what I would like to say but in
fact I am going to go to the airport
Hank you'll see me on Tuesday PS
nerdfighters the AFC wimbledon wimbly
wamba's have just played the most
important games in their history links
in the doobly-doo or you can click over
here